I look at Jamal Bowman and I'm like what
a
scumbag and this is why everything's
broken this is why everybody hates
Congress this is why nothing's getting
fixed this is why we're having all these
problems well I should say it is a
component of I think we have cultural
issues yeah but I I look at so so many
of these members of Congress and it's
it's crazy to me that Jamal Jamal Bowman
pulled the fire alarm Jamie Rasin
falsely accused me of advocating for
January
in in the in the j6 hearings yeah
because I reported on a Fox news story
that Donald Trump called for protests on
January 6 so before January 6 happens
I'm reading a news story from Fox News
where I'm like wow Trump's calling for a
protest that's going to get crazy like
things get crazy down there if Trump
calls for this yeah he runs clips of me
out of context included in a montage of
people screaming kick the door and and
things like this right that that that
guy's 20 minutes from here rasing people
who work at this company are he
represents them